m
pokémon ultrasone et ultra moon sorte
dans trois mois et je pense qu'il est
donc de temps pour moi de vous proposer
une vidéo théorie savait déjà prévu un
trois théories pour ce dernier mais les
théories en question était déjà
mentionné par beaucoup et il me manquait
les infos mais bref je suis très heureux
de vous parler de ce jeu tout comme son
prédécesseur l'an dernier donc c'est
parti pour cette théorie j'aimerais que
l'on se concentre sur le dernier trailer
annoncé par nintendo récapitulant toutes
les nouveautés des versions ultra nous
avons une connaissance d'une forme
crépusculaire de louga rock et autres
quelques nouveautés lambda comme le
physique des personnages jouables
cependant un détail retient tout
particulièrement mon attention dans ce
trailer et j'aimerais vous en parler
c'est un passage qui dure environ deux
secondes
et pourtant celui ci recèle bien des
secrets nous voyons le héros par les
assauts lan alias le roi du rock'n'roll
faut croire il était un adversaire pour
le titre de maître pokémon dans soleil
et lune mais ce n'est pas le plus
intrigant prenez le temps de regarder
l'image et regardez bien où se trouvent
les deux protagonistes
nous sommes dans l'arène de carmin sur
mer une arène de type électrique de la
région de canto est normalement tenues
par le major bob comment pourquoi est-ce
que j'en crois mes yeux ce sont les
questions que nous pouvons nous poser
est donc un gros mystère s'offre à nous
tout d'abord il faut savoir qu ado la
haye très lié à canto et notamment grâce
au professeur ford soit le maître de la
ligue pokémon
a la base je vous l'apprends pas fort
bien de canto était un très grand
dresseur de la région puis s'est
installé à lola une île en développement
il créera même une lit pour cette île et
contribuera énormément à son
développement
faut savoir aussi que dans soleil et
lune la région étaient en pleine
extension
le but principal est d'attirer des gens
du monde entier à parcourir sept régions
ultra soleil et ultra l'une sera donc le
futur de ses précédents jeux lille aura
donc énormément évolué et le tour des
îles évoluera normalement donc en
combats d'arène avec des badges à la clé
c'était prévu par forbes
un jour ou l'autre de plus ford est un
fan de la région de kanto qui prend
toujours comme référence c'est
probablement influencé des arènes de là
bas et ce serait pourquoi il y aurait
une arène ressemblant à celle de carmin
sur mer
avec le principe des poubelles à noter
que nous sommes bien dans le futur des
jeux pokémon arrêt des bleus ont
énormément grandi donc deux possibilités
s'offrent à nous soit la reine serait
tenu par christ qui est le capitaine de
l'épreuve électrique
donc il y aura un rapport ou bien la
reine serait fait exprès pour la venue
du major bob à allauch là après tout le
but de former de faire connaître l'île
c'est pour ça qu'ils nous encouragera
faire le tour des îles et devenir maître
de la ligue
nous avons déjà le cas avec les pokémon
de la 1 g qui possède une forme dalo là
c'est un retour aux sources qui fait
rêver les joueurs nostalgiques à lola
possède énormément de liens avec canto
et tout ceci rentrerait dans la
cohérence du jeu et serait une
excellente stratégie marketing de la
part de nintendo solane pourrait même
être peut être un rival du héros qui
sait se doit pas trop quoi rajouter de
plus beaucoup vous me demandez ce que je
pense de la forme de pokémon en étoile à
la fin du trailer certainement mais je
ne saurais pas trop quoi dire dessus sur
moi une forme lumineuse des nécroses ma
pourquoi pas cependant mon avis
personnel se pencherait pour leur réelle
inspiration de type-0 nécrose mas est
beaucoup plus fort que le sol galeo et
luna la ligne et le vase a entre
guillemets des ultras chimères et il
n'est pas aussi gentil que doudou qui
fut recueilli et élevé par lily qui
d'ailleurs accenture a fortement le lien
avec quant au fusain de france que nous
la reverrons après avoir soigné sa mère
en ramenant les eaux
parenthèse fermée cette forme pourrait
être le ok mone rival de nécrose mas qui
sait celui qui peut combattre les ultras
chimère tout comme type 0 il me fait
beaucoup penser à reus qui nous croyons
et l inspiration de type 0 mais
peut-être pas qui c'est je me pose
beaucoup de questions sur ses prochains
opus et ce qui est sûr c'est que je suis
impatient de la voie entre mes mains et
d'y jouer
j'espère que la vidéo vous aura plu
merci à ceux qui laisseront un pouce
bleus et qui partageront la vidéo
n'hésitez pas à me suivre sur twitter
pour les plus acharnés d'entre vous
c'est et argo rock et que le leinster ce
soit avec vous
[Musique]